House house comer as my spirit back
welcome to draw a stickman I just found
this game it looks pretty awesome guess
what you draw a stickman I'm not gonna
draw it okay so you draw your your
character or whatever I'm so tempted to
draw you know what I'm gonna draw but
I'm not gonna do that I'm gonna draw
something else I swear I didn't mean for
that what his name is Timmy and he has
feelings
my mom said do it again and do it
properly why it's is the only thing in
my brain
seriously pills use your imagination
imagine hey shun imagine alright let's
do a buff bro imagination imagination
imagine imagination do you even imagine
bro I forgot the most important part
there we go he's constantly pooping god
it looks like a hairy push that's great
best character in the game ever
his name is brah oh wait dragged a days
it's kind of lonely here
alright well I guess we scroll down with
a heat oh he needs a friend okay I can
do that what what should his friend be
um god damn this music man alright Larry
the lemon orange I mean that's his
friend oh god it oh yeah Larry why did I
get to name my friend but not him
alright let's go
adventure come on Kiki go come on brah
hey couple of days oh no not Larry now I
just drew him oh well I'll just draw
another one
oh well I guess I gotta save him
cuz I'm bruh I have to find Larry I am I
never gonna stop pooping the search for
Larry this guy's really also I like a
how to use fire pencil click the fire
pencil then draw the fire to burn
obstacles I have a fire pencil out of
nowhere let's draw this bun Cheney burn
burn burn are you on fire now
oh that's great that's just [ __ ] great
oh no the deadly oh no it's everywhere
oh no that poor tree I could just open
you but why not burn everything
oh god no prob breath protip avoid being
on fire Thanks alright let's just burn
one of the Bundy's cuz I don't like his
attitude
don't run it away from me see [ __ ] is
his problem alright never go flame on
rage going away [ __ ] love how he walks
so much [ __ ] swag can i [ __ ] off [ __ ]
[ __ ] are you guys smiling at you [ __ ]
they Mossad bag ha ha
a garvik who leaves out all the dynamite
don't think no that's dangerous
Oh got it
as close like I can't open it I don't
have to you are locked are my killer
pets all right what's next
what is it frost to rescue the Penguins
help help help help
don't worry I got this bro I got my son
10 I'm ready to do this ok so I can draw
a key pick up the key there you go and
then put it in works every time
Wow chop down a tree with it so I can
draw an axe alright let's do that looks
pretty legit let's jump you down [ __ ]
yep doing it
[ __ ] you I don't need an axe I have my
personal guillotine best axe ever ha ha
that's actually pretty legit oh my god
who would have thunk gay why did I say
that [ __ ] ok now I know how to handle
these a little better you just do like
this roof and then click oh why do you
have to die though our Lord and Savior
the swag Lord
oh don't chop down the tree what are you
doing ok damn it there we go open the
door swag Lord oh my God thank you
yeah we can keep going I'll bring you
with me swag Lord just to keep off
peasants
[ __ ] I know I press the penguin oh well
swag swag swag on you eating shampoo
while I'm eating shampoo I think that's
the lyrics
there's definitely something hiding here
I better get my axe wax out I was the
lamest actually it was pretty good
I'm pretty proud it's a double swag with
a butterfly on top there we go okay
there we go I'm in oh god you look ugly
let me help you ah all right I need my
spikes oh thy Holy Spirit of Justin
releases penguin by Holy Spirit of beeps
Oh God is scary
all right I get it what is it penguin
gonna do hey I have the sweater I have
the swag sticker no don't know that's
inappropriate okay oh damn he ain't
playing around
alright let's save yo let swag on you
so much swag I have so much swag it's
coming out of my genitals swag there you
go
they're all free right I got damn it
there's more yes
all right we did it it's pretty awesome
let's go here oh damn self exploding
stone sets did I just create like this
huge wildfire or some [ __ ] haha I don't
mean to do that I'm sorry hey Larry
Larry are you okay yeah you [ __ ]
no oh now the [ __ ] is that your
creativity sucks like a Larry's way
better no don't take Lenny what are you
gonna do to him well I better just burn
that [ __ ] wits by the power of swaggy
swaggy I condemn you to swag forever so
I need to start with this way oh it's a
salamander haters I love those the key
of a thousand tugs shall open this lock
open yes it looks so nasty
what the hell are they doing this get me
so worried or there's like dinosaurs and
tentacles
oh of course tentacles why 9 you know
what why not every game is good tentacle
you find a page best pages to read your
pages awesome
don't touch me brah oh good thing we
have the key of keys I got it Larry oh
[ __ ] he don't play around all right here
we go
I was pretty good fighting you in real
life Rock [ __ ] he's gonna die now isn't
he yes there are Mikkel bro is dead
that looks unlock this with my traps
take it why the [ __ ] did I do
yes I don't know what he's doing but I
don't tell you how to hit again you need
another one good thing I got quads for
us oh you [ __ ] I'm not gonna die here
all right you know what
best [ __ ] key ever [ __ ] you this is
the best day ever
you don't have a problem with this key
you have a problem with me brah
oh god what are you doing oh that makes
sense
everyone you see bidding the [ __ ] out of
that tentacle
laughs thanks bear thanks you Brian
really oh god no don't do that all right
oh that's fun
you won't like to vote yay all right
fresh hope you enjoyed it uh I first I
have two and a half to seven here but I
hope you enjoyed it's a it's a pretty
awesome game it's that it reminds me a
bit of Scribblenauts yeah uh leave a
like if you enjoyed watching I really
appreciate it it helps me out a lot bros
I'll see you in the next video that'd be
best